big tech companies are getting into bed
with communist China and it's having a
chilling effect on the world Apple's CEO
Tim Cook not looking so great after his
Company Limited a key iPhone function
used by Chinese anti-covered lockdown
protesters cook tried to smooth things
over by meeting with lawmakers on
Capitol Hill saying the changes Were
Meant to boost security but watch him
act like a total coward when confronted
by Fox Business reporter Hillary Vaughn
hi Mr cook do you support the Chinese
people's right to protest
foreign
do you have any reaction to the factory
workers that were beaten and detained
for protesting coveted lockdowns
do you regret restricting airdrop access
that protesters used to evade
surveillance from the Chinese government
do you think it's problematic to do
business with the Communist Chinese
party when they suppress human rights
that comes as we get a disturbing new
report on how China used Tick Tock in
order to tip the scales in our midterms
apparently accounts run by the
propaganda arm of the Chinese government
have accumulated millions of followers
they were bashing Republicans and
praising Democrats without really
clearly disclosing they were being
posted by a foreign government so
Hillary Vaughn really drew some blood
out there on Old Timmy didn't she I
gotta tell you Hillary Vaughn is now my
hero I mean she just had one after the
other after the other look how
disappointing and that's very that's a
very soft word is it that the head of
Apple is literally taking a position
that the Chinese government wants the
only country in the world that wants to
limit airdrop so that the protesters uh
can evade actually the policing by the
Chinese Communists and communicate with
each other because once they're
identified as protesters are taken in
they're beaten and we never hear from
them again and from for for Tim Cook to
say to not answer question when it is so
anti-democratic and and it's all about
the money for him and then to watch the
the opposite of that with Twitter you
know we're now learning Twitter's now
involved in the election or was involved
in the 2020 election and was was um
putting certain information higher up or
suppressing certain information and then
the hunter laptop on top of it the
United States government is now in the
business of suppressing free speech and
they're doing it for political purposes
and that is just plain wrong and Elon
Musk said he's going to release some
information about the situation of the
laptop and we'll bring that to you if we
see it come in
so the CEO didn't say a word is that a
good strategy or should he have stopped
and talked to our very own Hillary
Vaughn well I agree Hillary Vaughn did a
great job it's good to be back back with
everybody
we've been missing you um we're in the
middle just to take a step back we're in
the middle of I think of a reset uh
around the scope in terms of our
relationship economic relationship with
China I think it's unfair to put the
onus of the burden on one CEO to try to
answer although I probably would have
had an answer I would have expressed
people should have had some sort of
response knowing that he might be asked
these questions but In fairness we on
this Set uh have been critical of
Business Leaders when they get in the
middle of politics uh and I have not
always so I'm being consistent I think
he should have answered those questions
but at the same time we can't expect a
CEO of a large company to help determine
what is larger government in public
policy needs to be sorted out that's no
excuse for not not answering the
question here are the terms with the
judge in all fairness hear the terms
that are are being talked about you have
IP concerns you have access to their
markets access to our markets you have
National Security concerns you have
trade concerns you have a support of
illicit regimes or should say hostile
regimes all this has to be sorted out at
the federal level and at a larger policy
level again we have to have a reset
though before these these ideas and for
that matter these matters are going to
be resolved finally I think of as we
talk about the people there in China we
can shake our heads but these are real
issues we you buy products I'm trying to
so if you really feel as strongly as you
do and I believe you do you should stop
wearing devouring food
of buying things that are made in China
Cook
Chinese people to invade uh uh to convey
he's the president of the company
no he should have answered it's the only
country in the world then give throw
your Apple away throw that phone away
right now if you feel that strong you
know why you're not going to do that
because you don't feel that [ __ ] I do if
you don't feel that's true
kinds of issues that have to be
litigated at the federal this is policy
and there's there's federal policy that
needs to be reset I'm agreeing with you
but if you feel as strong as you do I'm
not throwing away throw it away what do
you agree that these matters need to be
resolved and Tim Cook probably should
have answered matters need to be answer
the questions
that's not the no that's not the answer
it probably was made why you think it's
a good idea to identify protesters who
end up being killed as a result of the
Communist Chinese party I don't know I
agree with you you should have asked
that question but us consumers
let's move on Kennedy are you interested
in what Elon might be releasing to the
world about the hunter Biden cover-up
I'm actually I am interested in that
because I think there's a lot that's
been happening we know it's been
happening and he's going to give us
confirmation of that that's that's what
I expect but to Harold's point because
you sort of mush together about four
different things part of that is the US
government part of that is Apple but the
way you talk about it it's as though
it's one entity which is the most
concerning thing we face in this country
big Tech and big government getting
together okay because yes Apple has to
worry about market share above market
share is human freedom and having access
to talking with other people
coordinating protests and standing up
against an authoritarian murderous
regime that's what Tim Cook could have
allowed the United States government
they have to figure out what is our
foreign policy how do we interface as a
country with China but to the judge's
Point these inalienable god-given human
rights are above what Apple might make
appeasing the Communist Chinese party
Elon Musk in contrast fast made starlink
available to Ukrainian people so they
could coordinate and get themselves and
their families to safety and also have
some sort of a vigilante offense on
their own Tim Cook could have done the
same thing opening up airdrop to these
desperate people they're left holding up
white pieces of paper blind pieces of
paper to symbolize what they would like
to say but they could not because they
have been silenced by the company I'm
not on that side I said he should have
asked answered that question I'm only
saying there's a larger set of issues
here to have to be litigated if we feel
that strongly throw your iPhone away no
that's not what it is
he shouldn't have done it I am
pro-america I am against them I'm not
going to allow you to align me with them
if you feel it strongly throw your dog
on iPhone are you with them
Jimmy listen uh in all due respect to
these lovebirds down the end
[Laughter]
yeah it's so embarrassing you know what
he looked like he looked like me walking
past one of those environmental people
with the clipboards on Sixth Avenue do
you have two seconds for climate no I
don't as a matter of fact and the cause
has changed seven times it was you have
two minutes we're freezing do you have
two minutes we're gonna melt but stick
with me okay you can't tell me we don't
have free speech problems when the CEO
of the biggest company in the world
isn't allowed to talk to the media they
told him to shut up that's media
Training 101 because he knows if he
responds he amplifies the story and
that's what we were watching in that
moment is him realizing it's time to
play a little bit of Defense but every
one of these companies that throws up a
rainbow or Ukrainian flag or a pronoun
doesn't care about human rights and if
they did they'd have the balls to say
something because people are dying and
it's not as simple Harold as just
divesting ourselves from this technology
because this technology has its own set
of entanglements and considerations so I
get what you're trying to say which is
not if you really feel that way but if
Apple really felt that way just give
China the finger are they an American
company are they a Chinese company I
think what we learned is there a Chinese
company
look all
those kind of shoes between my phone and
phone it would help pave a way around
these human rights issues and it is not
that's my only point do you have to have
a reset with this relationship sure I
don't think we should go this way
but no no but everything has to be
redone here and it's National Security
it's it's Capital markets all of these
things how do we do that sit down and
talk to them I don't think so you know
if we I think our big to bring in all
these companies to the White House and
figure out what is it that you're
willing to do what is it that you cannot
do what can we produce
we would have to I would invite him I
would ask president
why is Tick Tock running so free that's
a Chinese company yeah
that's the good point about Tick Tock
Heralds if you add mini made off buying
the Senate with fraudulent Cash and The
Tick Tock interference that's right that
is a double dose of election
interference
has been the most outspoken person
100 we agree on that we agree all right
Mark Warren owner hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else